[音楽]
dee
tee
みなさんこんちゃん
もうちょっと動く仕組みの下世屋さんお兄ちゃ
ああ
経由地江東覚悟のハイ汁好きです
本日はですねこの想定外の向き合い方こちらをテーマに市でお話をしていきたいと
おもいます
ところで紹介もありましたように私
金券一高校生で所望試験に合格するという異色の経歴を持っています
そこで
まずは私がどれほど希少品安価ということについてお話をしていきたいとおもいます
みなさんが好きなできてなんでしょうか
生え雲に雨と雪
いろいろあると思うんですけれどもその中で私が一番大好きな定期
それは台風です
愛をこいつ頭おかしいなと思う楽しいんですけれども
こそへいった感じですねまず者台風が来る蒸留したり接近した reald いう話を
聞くともうこう主下手ですね一日中テレビの前から離れないなんていうことも目指し
ありません
まあそのですね偏った感性の持ち主である私ですから
幼い時からまあ選びてしまうこともよくありました
例えば幼稚園の是非
マイが民雷を取れみんなビビっているのが窓の外を見て興奮するパパが一人ん
小学校のとき周りが一人の車が縁で楽しんでいる中ん
ありませ電球総会で厚遇するバーガーでした
中学校の時多い情報に目を輝かせ
一日中命令画像に張り続けたばから来ていん
これもちろん私の話なんですけれども
ですねこういったような風たですねはい気象予報地としての
導いたわーこの日承諾としての素質が赤じゃない
そういうふうに考えております
ブーブー h しかあり中22出版そう
共有して企業を送っております
まあ
ここまでですね私の木も着弾存分ずつあったかと思いますので高価な
より問題について話していくために私が中学1年生の時に取り組んだ
動作点こちらに話を移していきたいとおもいます
労作店聞き覚えのある方もいらっしゃると思うんですけれども
普通後にはロー作戦というすべての生徒たちが自分の興味ある分野についての研究
あるいは芸術作品を作成しそれを発表するというイベントが毎年開かれています
中学一年生の私はこの機会台風の観測研究をシェルなと言い義妹ておりました
台風の観測には準備が必要ですから
実際に気象庁に入って処理報酬の諸先輩方から指導を仰いでい
台風活動の準備を進めておりました
地稼ぎ北3-8月
し食堂と付けます
そう
台風がからっ
谷黒関数をするために準備をしていたのに感じのタイプのバッ
これには10学生の早いですけど相当ありました
ん
しかしいつまでまっせってなあに3回目に行きません
さてどうなって対応していく
私は
台風の観測の台風と日々の便器これを比較するために行なっていた
8月分の気象観測データこれに目をつけました
だいぶの家族すらできなかったもの8月の一ヶ月分ではれとも一生関数の泥炭あるいは
写真だ
こういう使えるんじゃないかそういうふうに問題です
そしてですね提出学ぶ2週間という制度にはで私は大幅な軌道修正を行い大賞の観測
から日々の天気の観測トレをテーマに論文を書き上げることにいたしました
その時の写真がこちらです
我ながらでき凪
曲時間サンオイルですよねぇーごぼうないよいよ音大について語っていきたいと思うん
ですけれども
そのために今回のロー昨年の1年での出来事を振り返っていこうと思います
まず台風の観測の計画棒だけだ
そしてその漢族を遂行するために準備を行っ
そして台風が来るのに今や遅しと待っていたわけですけれども
台風が来ることはなかっ
私の計画破断窮地に立たされましたん
このとき私は大きな焦りを感じたわけですけれども
良本を書き上げましてフリーな時間ができた時ふと疑問に思うことがあります
同棲想定外に直面した時に合わせてしまったんだろうか
まだこの焦りさえ無ければ想定外に対してどーってことない
そんな風に思えるんじゃないかそう思いました
そこでここからはどうしてませてしまったか
そしてどうすれば焦らなくなるのかこれをお伝えしていこうと思います
まずそもそも想定外って何だろうか
想定のでいいこれはこう前よりある一定の状況や条件を仮に思い描くととされています
ですからそうではないつまり自分の思い描いてなかったことを今大会は台風が来なかっ
たところこれ
想定外に対応します
次に自分が想定外に直面したとき何でももう止められるのか
自分が思い描いていなかったことを考えの及ばなかったものについて考えでもありませ
ん
つまり柔軟な思考であったり対応力ポイントも求められることになります
しかしこれ不安であればできることかもしれません
しかし想定外に直面した直後です同様免れないでしょう
こういったことを考えてしまうかもしれません
次元今に言うだろうかとか
そもそも目標完成できるんだろうか
こういった不安を感じてしまうと思うんですけれどもここで不安を感じてしまうほど
これが焦りが始まりです
2件焦り始めるとどんどんゴールしか見えない
そんなん視野狭窄に用いてしまいます
するとさらにゴールだと重くそして壁について会が入らなくなってしまう
するとさらにゴールだと思う
こういったん悪循環
今こそが焦りの全貌なのです
しかしお話ぼ
この焦りの悪循環さに断ち切ってしまえば増税が可愛いものではありません
解決法について探っています
まず不安を感じてしまう焦りを感じ焦りを感じてしまう
ショックの高原は不安を感じてしまうことです
ですから
不安を感じないように労働と家で構えで想定外に愚痴や魚
これは非常に重要です
なんかおり早いな
はなんだろ
このようにランク的にももっと行う
これは想定外に対して非常に有効な手段と言えず
続いて状況把握ですよ
自分の計画がどこまで進んでいるのかそして想定がにはでどこまで考え直さなければ
ならないのか
これをハグすることによって自分成人状態をより通常に近づけることができます
蘇生落ち着いている精神状態になったら最後ステップ
新たな計画も考えていきます
自分年しっかりとした準備をしておけば一つのボールしかないということは決してあり
ません
むしろ当初の計画よりかえってよいものができるそういうふうに私は思います
私の例なんですけれども今回はどう昨年議論失礼してからの方がうまくローンを
書き上げることができましたし最終的には以下競技数グリが一人の方からこその作品賞
をいただくことができました
軌道修正のファイターと想定外の前と後ではあともうが悪い
そんな固定観念は必要ありませんむしろアートのほど良いより良いものができる
私はそう思います
労働と構えるほど
状況把握もすることそしてその先を見据えること
この3ステップを追い抜けば想定外ば怖いものではありません
最後になりますが想定外は必ずしも議員地ではない
むしろ挑戦できればね自分をそう提案の境地へ旅立たせてくれるそんな存在であると
いうこと
今日はこれを覚えて頂ければというふうに思います
最後までのご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]